-Last weekend, right,
was a big weekend for you.
It was you and Justin's
wedding anniversary.
-Yes.
-That's right.
What is it, seven years now?
-Seven years.
Can you believe that?
-It was seven years ago?
-Oh, my God.
-I had so much fun
at your wedding.
It was the best,
most beautiful wedding.
I loved it.
-The only problem
with that wedding is
I didn't get to go as a guest.
-Yeah.
-I want to go back as a guest.
But you -- You had the most fun
at that wedding.
-Do you remember
your speech that you made?
[ Both laugh ]
-I don't remember any of this.
-During Justin's speech
that he made?
-Uh-huh. I kind of do.
-During our reception, Justin
was giving this beautiful --
"Thank you so much for coming.
You flew so far.
This means the world to us.
You're our, you know,
most beloved."
And over in the corner,
there were these terrarium
things, remember,
with the big glass lids?
And you put it on your head,
and you just stood up
like a weird,
old-school scuba diver
or some sort of an astronaut
or something?
-Yeah, I think I was -- Yeah,
swimming around or something.
-You were interrupting him,
and he was laughing back at you,
and I thought,
"Thank God this is Jimmy,"
'cause if it wasn't you --
-I would be thrown out
of the wedding.
-Thrown out. Gone.
-Yeah, I kind of remember that.
It was these giant fish bowls.
-These giant fish bowl things.
-Yeah, I just put one on
and, like, started pretending
I was an astronaut.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah. Anyways --
-I remember that.
-I'm happy that you invited me.
Thank you.
That's why I don't get invited
to any weddings anymore.
Yeah. Isn't that weird?
-Well, you can always --
If I get married again,
to him again, you can come.
-I will.
-The remix.
-The remix? Okay, I'll be there.
When you guys renew your vows,
I'll be there.
I was hearing this.
I was doing some research
on this interview,
and I saw somewhere, it came up,
that you were never really
an NSYNC fan when they were out.
-Well --
No. But -- But --
-Were you like
a Backstreet Boys fan?
-No, no, no. I was --
I was a, like, a lame music-y --
not lame.
I was just listening
to old-school stuff.
I was -- I was listening
to theater productions.
I was listening to "Rent."
I was like --
knew every word of "Rent."
I was listening to Motown.
I was listening
to old-school stuff.
I, like, lived under a rock.
I just -- I wasn't
into pop culture music.
-'Cause we actually found
an interview of Jessica Biel
during those times
that NSYNC was around.
It's pretty -- It's pretty
interesting to see.
-Jimmy, Jimmy.
-This is years before
you and Justin ever met.
-No, please.
-Here's Jessica Biel in 1999
being asked...
-No, no, please.
-...if she's an NSYNC fan.
Take a look.
-Oh.
To be honest,
I don't really listen --
I haven't really -- I mean,
I know of them, of course.
And I've heard of them,
and I've heard the music.
I don't think I own
any of their CDs.
I'm not a huge fan.
Um...
But, I mean, cool, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
You're in so much trouble.
Dude, you're in
so, so much trouble.
Oh, my God. My God, I mean --
"Cool, I guess."
Oh, my God.
-The attitude.
-Your attitude you had, yeah.
But you don't know --
You don't know --
I figure now you probably know
some NSYNC songs. Right?
-Not really.
[ Laughter ]
I-I mean, listen,
it became very clear to me
just a month ago
when we were with our friends.
We were hanging out again
in Italy somewhere,
and we were trying
to play Truth or Dare,
which is the dumbest thing to do
with a bunch of, like,
late 30-year-olds.
-Yeah.
-It was a bad idea.
Everyone knows each other's
truth. So it's boring.
-Yeah, you're just like,
"Let's just play Dare."
-So we just played Dare.
And my dare was
I have to sing an NSYNC song,
all the lyrics,
all the melodies,
and I literally -- I couldn't.
I only know three words.
"Bye, bye, bye."
[ Laughter ]
Which is, I guess,
one word three times.
-That's one word three times.
But still, that's the one.
That's the one to know.
-And I wasn't allowed
to sing that.
I had to sing something else.
Justin coached me through
the chorus, the verse.
-Oh, no.
-I'm looking at the words.
It was so embar--
It was humiliating.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Really humiliating.
-I love it. It's hilarious.
We should both work on --
We'll find a song and do a duet
and surprise Justin.
-Would you help me?
-Yeah, I will help you. Yeah.
We'll do it, yeah.
'Cause I'm a giant fan.
-I know.
-You do know that. Right? Yeah.
-I want to know talk about
your show "Limetown."
This is on Facebook Watch.
This is good that --
You're starring in this.
You executive-produced this.
And this is based on this
podcast that was fascinating.
-Yes.
-It was really cool.
-Did you love it?
-Yes, I --
-Oh, I loved it so much.
-Who -- Who did
the podcast again?
-Well, Zack Akers
and Skip Bronkie,
they created this podcast.
They -- And they
created the story.
I thought it was real.
-No, at first.
Yeah, because, me, too.
-100% real.
I was into true crime stuff.
-But this is at the time --
Me, too.
-So I thought for sure
this is something I missed.
The news goes so quickly.
-Like a true crime podcast.
And what is the story again?
-So, the story is this town,
this small kind of, um, uh,
science community --
Sort of everyone in the town
disappears one day.
And there's -- there's no --
no leads, no nothing.
It's like the town was full
of people one day.
The next day, it's just empty.
-Yeah.
-And that was 15 years
in the past.
So when we start our show,
my character's
an investigative journalist,
and she has her own podcast,
and she actually has
a personal connection.
One of her family members
is one of the missing.
So, she wants to open up
the case, and she gets a lead.
And then you go into the story.
-But it is --
It's a fantastic story.
And it's done so well by you.